people think they know the story they
think it's a story about one man but
when you pull back the curtain it's
actually about so much more
a recent Netflix documentary series
called Madoff the monster of Wall Street
by Emmy award-winning filmmaker Joe
Berlinger tells the story of the largest
Ponzi scheme in history how could he
fool so many people for so long
what happened was so avoidable and so
many people enabled it to happen because
of greed
the film's other villain is the
Securities and Exchange Commission which
received complaints about Madoff
starting in the early 1990s and yet not
only failed to catch him but helped
enable his fraud during one
investigation all SEC investigators had
to do which checked the routing number
to verify a trade had actually occurred
which it hadn't of course because all of
madoff's Trades were fake you could have
shut Madoff down in one half hour by
just following up on one of his
allegations that they were not
conducting trades if you are the
Watchdogs you have totally and
thoroughly failed in your mission
don't you get it the Netflix series
acknowledges that the SEC is complicit
in Madoff scam and that he could have
been caught if one investigator assigned
to the case had done about 30 minutes of
checking they asked the question they
got the information they got the account
number
but they never made the phone call
inconceivable and I never got an answer
that made any sense to be honest from
the people that we questioned under oath
in depositions about this particular
point
they forgot they missed it
but it just doesn't make any sense
it also claims deregulation and free
market capitalism for making the fraud
possible
the first episode sets the stage with a
speech by Ronald Reagan it is high taxes
excessive spending and over regulation
had thrown a wrench in the works of our
free markets our economic program for
the next four years we're going to turn
the bull loose
in episode 3 journalist Diana henriquez
makes the connection explicit resources
that had been in New York City on wall
Street's doorstep devoted to
white-collar Crime to fraud
were being steered away we're being
funneled into counterterrorism and
terrorism Finance issues
for the SEC this was an exacerbation of
an existing problem
as a result of a deregulatory campaign
that began with the election of Ronald
Reagan in 1980. in this present crisis
government is not the solution to our
problem
government is the problem
the laws that they could rely on to
pursue investigations had been tightened
and their budgets had been cut and cut
again
and yet nothing in the film would lead
one to draw the conclusion that the SEC
needed a bigger budget to catch Madoff
in fact Outsiders were sounding the
alarm without access to Government
funding or regulatory muscle in 2001
Barron's journalist Aaron everland
reported that many Wall Street investors
were suspicious that Madoff was engaged
in Foul Play and the SEC received its
first complaint that Madoff was running
an unregistered Investment Company
offering 100 percent safe investments in
1992. in 1999 a derivatives expert named
Harry markopoulos who worked at a
competing firm started to alert the SEC
that madoff's investment returns were
virtually impossible
in 2005 markopolis sent the agency an
Infamous 25-page memo explaining why the
world's largest hedge fund is a fraud
the SEC opened an investigation in 2006
and then closed it the following year
because the uncovered violations were
remedied and those violations were not
so serious as to Warrant an enforcement
action we knew then that we had provided
enough red flags
and mathematical proofs
where they should have been able to shut
him down right then and there
unfortunately as they didn't respond to
my written submissions in 2000 2001 2005
2007 and 2008. here we are today so how
is this tale of epic failure on the part
of a government agency the fault of
deregulation
instead of making lazy allusions to the
evils of free market capitalism to
better understand the lessons of the
Madoff Saga director Joe Berlinger
should have consulted the work of the
free market Economist George Stigler who
won the Nobel Prize in part for his work
on regulatory capture in a 1971 paper
the theory of economic regulation
Stigler argues that while many people
believe that regulation has instituted
primarily for the protection and benefit
of the public in fact it mainly serves
the purposes of the largest companies
being regulated which form a symbiotic
relationship with their regulatory
overseers
and for the industry it is regulated and
not as a matter of venality not as a
matter of lack of Integrity or a lack of
confidence but the political realities
of Life dictates that the regulatory
bodies become affiliated with and helped
in what it believed to be the necessary
conditions for the survival of the skin
dispute the essay focuses mainly on how
Regulators help existing companies by
protecting them from competition but
stigler's Theory can also be used to
better understand the sec's failure to
catch Madoff in a 1972 essay Stigler
writes that their regulating agency must
eventually become the agency of the
regulated industry they need each other
that's because the career lawyers at the
SEC making the decisions have much more
to gain personally from having a
positive relationship with Big Industry
players than antagonizing them
this is also what happened in the case
of Sam bankman freed who was close with
politicians and regulators and actively
lobbied for regulation of the crypto
industry in a bid to Elbow out
competitors right up to the moment that
his crypto exchange FTX collapsed under
the weight of its own alleged fraud this
cozy relationship between industry and
Regulators helps explain why the SEC
continually missed what was right in
front of them in the Madoff case when
Harry Marco polos was trying to persuade
the SEC
that a gigantic historically huge Ponzi
scheme was being run at that very minute
by Bernie Madoff
he was facing an enormous challenge
because the SEC relied on Bernie Madoff
as a source of Wall Street wisdom
he had a tremendous reputation as being
one of the real giants of Wall Street
not only for developments that he helped
launch changes in the industry that he
helped Define
but he also spent a lot of time working
with the SEC and other government
agencies on panels and assisting with
how to regulate business Madoff even
spread the rumor that he was being
considered as a future chairman of the
SEC at one point he tells them that he
is on the short list to become the next
head of the SEC
and there's email communication between
these two Junior examiners and their
boss where the boss says to them in
joking maybe you can be Bernie's aides
when he comes to take over the SEC
so they're awestruck to begin with can
all this depend on Ronald Reagan
deregulation in the free market one guy
LED you to this pile of dung that is
that is Bernie Madoff and stuck your
nose in it and you couldn't figure it
out is the SEC too cozy with the
industry are they captive by this
industry are they looking out for us
looking out for the taxpayers the
documentary also makes a strong case
that the SEC didn't just fail to catch
Madoff investors were emboldened by the
agency's investigation of Madoff and
failure to find serious violations such
as this man who gave Madoff the proceeds
from the sale of his small business the
fact that the SEC found no evidence of
wrongdoing was to me putting a stamp of
approval on Madoff so
I sent a wire for nine hundred thousand
dollars to made up
that regulation is primarily for the
protection and benefit of the public at
large or some large subclass of the
public Stigler rights is a commonly held
View
but it's not SEC investigators didn't
want to be overly combative with Madoff
because they thought doing so could hurt
their careers
regulation exists largely to serve the
interests of the people being regulated
the illusion of competent regulation
gave investors a false sense of security
that drove them to make colossal
mistakes can the answer really be more
regulation what if Harry markopolis's
warnings hadn't been filtered through
the SEC the average person is better
equipped to spot a con man than we give
him credit for but the myth that
Regulators are primarily motivated to
protect the interests of the public
causes us to suspend our better judgment
the individual consumers if it is not
hampered is in general capable of a
large measure of self-defense against
frauds mishaps bad luck and the light in
economic and social life
uh not all consumers are intellectually
competent and well informed but most
consumers know how to build up defenses
Against The medievous Institute that lie
in real life
and it is primarily because we have
socially so often hampered his effects
that we have injured the consumers the
big takeaway from Madoff the monster of
Wall Street is that Regulators
unwittingly facilitated his fraud just
as they helped Sam bankman freed run his
ledged con as you watch the Netflix
series think about how much more time or
power should we really give them
are they helping us
or themselves
[Music]